the Candyman according to legend if you
look into a mirror and chant his name
five times he will appear behind you and
his hook will be the last thing you ever
see but who is the Candyman the story
itself first appeared in 1890 after the
death of a painter in Chicago the
Candyman was the son of a slave who
became extremely wealthy when he
invented a machine that allowed him to
mass-produce shoes during the American
Civil War the man was able to send his
son to all of the best schools in
America and as a result he grew up to
become a good-natured gentleman and an
established painter the young man was
commissioned by a wealthy landowner to
paint his daughter
the painter fell in love of the land on
his daughter and they would eventually
have a child outside of wedlock when the
girl's father discovered their
relationship he was outraged
he hired a lynch mob to find and kill
the painter eventually they cornered the
painter in a barn and they cut off his
right hand of a rusty blade they smeared
his body with honey and watched as bee
stung him to death future generations of
the neighborhood old christened him the
Candyman the Candyman is a tower and six
foot five inches tall he wears a brown
fur trench coat a white cravat around
his neck grey pants and polished leather
shoes he has a bloody hook in place of
his right hand which he uses to mutilate
his victims the trench coat is used to
cover the grotesque mutilations he
suffered underneath it reveals he
skinless ribcage and he's hollowed out
abdomen he's organs infested by the bees
that live within him
in the second Candyman movie we find out
that his name is Daniel
sometime after his death Daniels ghost
rose from the grave and became a
vengeful spirit who will torment
anyone who dares to question his
existence his only goal was to keep the
stories and rumors surrounding his death
alive as he believed if people feared
him he would be able to continue
hunt the land and so the legend arose
anyone who shall recite the name
Candyman five times in the mirror then
immediately turn off the lights or
summon the ghosts who will slay all that
have witnessed its appearance the
Candyman is immortal and cannot be
killed by conventional means however it
is believed that there is a mirror that
contains his soul and is the source of
his power if the mirror is destroyed he
will cease to exist
if you've enjoyed this video then please
go ahead and leave it a like consider
subscribing if folklore mythology is
something that interests you if you have
anything you'd like to discuss or have
any ideas for future videos then please
go ahead and let me know in the comments
below as always I've been your host
mythology and folklore explained
[Music]